I'd like to welcome everyone to today's
symposium entitled aging research at
Yale past present and future we have a
very exciting afternoon planned I'm tom
gill and I direct the claudi pepper
older Americans independence center at
Yale which is sponsoring today's
symposium I'd like to express my
gratitude to several persons who have
worked tirelessly to plan and organize
today's activities including denisa
Cabrera Eliza killick & Robin Bonanno in
geriatrics Kerry fav a Mary who and
michael fitt Sousa and the dean's office
Karen pert and public affairs and
communication Susanna samajh II in the
development office in the entire
leadership of the pepper Center before I
make my first introduction I'd like to
briefly review a few housekeeping items
first there will be a ten-minute break
about halfway through the program at
four-thirty the restroom is on the
mezzanine level with access either
through the elevator from the ground
floor up or through the back door at the
top of the room staff members from the
program and aging will be in the aisles
to assist you if needed second we've
distributed index cards perhaps as you
are walking into the room as a mechanism
to solicit questions for our panel
discussion which will take place at the
end of the program if you'd like to ask
a question please jot it down on the
index card during the talks and our
staff will collect the cards at the end
of each row following the talks if you
would like to direct your question to
one of our speakers please indicate that
on the index card finally for those who
have cell phones if we ask you just to
put them on vibrate mode if you wouldn't
mind so we don't disturb our speakers I
not like to introduce the dean of yale
school of medicine dr. robert l /
dr. alpern is a nephrologist otherwise
known as a kidney expert before assuming
his current position in 2004 dr. Alpern
was on the faculty at University of
California San Francisco and University
of Texas Southwestern Medical Center in
Dallas where he served as dean from 1998
to 2004 dr. Alpern has been an
outstanding Dean and leader and we are
fortunate that he was able to join us
for today's symposium dr. Alpert it's
it's a real pleasure to be here today to
share the celebration when I was in
Dallas I one of the things we wanted to
do was to build a geriatrics program and
we realized how difficult it was going
to be and then I realized the easiest
way to do it was to move to Yale the so
this is the claude d pepper older
Americans independence center is really
one of the jewels of Yale University and
you know clearly I think we have a
geriatrics division that's the size of
many departments at Yale actually larger
than many departments at Yale so the
program in aging was established in 1991
and we were designated as a pepper
Center in 1992 and Tom just renewed I
think for the fifth cycle following Mary
the NIH Center and we've heard that the
center programs are alive and well at
the NIH so they should be many more
cycles the the setters purpose that was
shown to me is to enhance health
well-being and independence of older
Americans and I think that that's really
speaks to what geriatrics is about you
know really understand
that it's not just keeping people alive
but there's a lot more to life and to
try and keep people really healthy and
able to take care of themselves and so
the the center has been incredible and
the numbers report to me they have 50
investigators in more than 70 research
projects and the ultimate goal is that
to match longevity with the quality of
life and I think this is going to be one
of the big four fronts for medicine in
the next 50 years because I we're
getting really good at beating down
heart disease we're getting better and
better at cancer and people are just
going to keep living longer and longer I
think one of the major economic problems
that this country is going to face is if
people live to a hundred and thirty can
they afford for them to stop working at
65 and I think it actually we are
getting to this point where we need to
stay strong not just alive for longer
for the fur to all work and so that's
what this Center is about and so I do
want to acknowledge the support of the
NIH we're delighted that Richard Harris
is here today from the National
Institute of aging he's a yale college
graduate so he has his ties here
although he did wander up to Boston for
medical school but we do appreciate
their support and as I said the funds
that have come here have really allowed
the center to support investigators all
across Yale University the I think
there's like total funding of 33 million
dollars that have come through the
center with an estimate that it's led to
about 200 million dollars in grant
funding and so
I think it's it's an incredible success
in one of the real unique strengths of
Yale University so that's the end of my
comments and now I'm pleased to
introduce the next speaker so when they
gave me the points that I was supposed
to cover today they told me that well
you need to know that what rosa DeLauro
is going to speak about so that you
don't say the same thing she's going to
say and I said no it's no problem
because I'm going first so it's my
pleasure though to introduce to you a
dear friend and actually a friend of
everyone in this room because of her
support for what we all tried to do Rosa
was elected to the House of
Representatives in 1990 a year before
the program and aging was started she is
the ranking member on the labor Health
Human Services and education
Appropriations Committee and she can
share that with you she serves on a
subcommittee responsible for the FDA the
science coalition recognized her as the
2012 champion of science and Rosa is a
spirited relentless and inspiring leader
and advocate for science and I can tell
you that as a Dean I'm continuously on
conference calls where other Dean's and
people tell me you need to speak to your
congressperson and tell them to support
the NIH and I always tell them that
would be a waste of time for me here
because Rosa is more committed to the
NIH than I am Rosa please
thank you so much thank you that was
very kind to refer to me as spirited
remember my colleagues would just say
you know da downright abrasive and
aggressive is what they would that what
they would say about me but I am honored
so honored to be here with all of you
today yo still I'm a townie is so many
of you know born and raised in the city
of New Haven and the Yale buildings are
still somewhat intimidating you know
when you when you come into them but
it's wonderful to see such a crowd here
this afternoon on such an incredibly
important topic and so many
distinguished folks who are here and
we're going to speak with you I just to
what work that is done at the quad a
pepper center here is and it's going on
for 20 years and it is about saving
lives it's about pushing the frontiers
of knowledge and it's about improving
the quality of life for older Americans
and that is well as what you said then
it is about the quality of life because
we have figured out how to have people
live longer but what is happening to
them in those those years and and how is
it going what what is what are their
lives are about and so that whatever
their cognition is that they sense is
that their their life is still filled
with some meaning and what what they are
what they are doing and that's
critically important to me and I'll
explain that in a moment to you so that
the work at Yale is complemented by the
work at 15 other pepper research centers
across the country due to a foundation
and I wanted to mention this laid by an
incredible incredible human being and
that was senator and representative a
claude pepper he served in both
capacities and i would just get into a
pattern where we also always mentioned
the senate first rather than the house
but
and the Senate is dysfunctional and so
is the house as dysfunctional these days
but in any case he was a man really
someone that after my own heart and I
obviously I was in New Jersey doing the
Mondale Ferraro campaign when 1984 and
plug pepper came in to do some helping
out so I never did I oh it's it was an
admiration from afar of what this this
man was it was all about as a senator he
advocated for national health care equal
pay for equal work for women cancer and
heart disease heart disease research
programs and a minimum wage he also
co-opted the legislation that
established the National Cancer
Institute the first of the many national
institutes of health Institute's at the
NIH in his later years he served in the
US House as chairman of the Select
Committee on Aging and was known as the
quote spokesperson for the elderly and
indeed an eloquent spokesperson for the
elderly so that the aging research
centers could not have been named for a
better advocate for the elderly and here
at the Yale pepper Center over 100,000
what over one thousand manuscripts have
been published based on work supported
by the center over the last 20 years and
over the last 10 years the center has
awarded over 200 million dollars in
research grants and career development
awards to scientists and scholars who
are pushing at aging research across a
number of disciplines from immunology to
genetics psychology to physical therapy
cardiology to nursing and with that in
mind I would like to acknowledge and say
thank you to the speakers who are
devoting their time this afternoon to
this symposium some of the most
accomplished leaders in the field among
them dr. Mary tinetti the MacArthur
Genius grant winner who led the founding
of the pepper center in 1992 the first
investigator to identify
that older adults at risk for falling
and injury could be identified and while
dr. Gianetti has all of those wonderful
credentials I would just say personally
to her that her care of my 99 year old
mother is at the top of that of that top
of that list and my mother is not easy
to care for let me tell you and dr.
Gianetti would would concur in that
effort so dr. Stephen Strittmatter lab
is conducting important work in
combating Alzheimer's repairing nerves
after traumatic spinal cord injury and I
was honored to tour the lab and see the
work that was being done by him and by
others and that we did it in 2011 and
again that was it a period of time when
we were experiencing what was being a
reduction in and funding for research
and we were trying to make the case of
how backward that is and so and we'll
talk a little bit about that as well
today of what's going on dr. Nicholas
Christakis director of Yale's human
nature lab conducted pioneering research
into health social networks has been
called one of the most influential
thinkers in the world by both time and
foreign policy dr. sandy Chang whose lab
at Yale conducts cutting-edge research
into not I'm not a scientist so is it
tell amores huh I don't say always
Italian whenever I look at one of these
words so you know in any case the
protein DNA complexes that caps the
chromosomes how mutations and this
binding proteins can lead to increased
risk of cancer I'm going to use my best
baseball analogy here and if you're a
Yankee fan you'll understand this this
is murderers row of talent here an
expert in aging research on and to dr.
Otis at the National Institute of aging
thank you thank you thank you for the
great work that's being done there
niña the principal federal funding
agency for age ageing research here at
Yale and all across America like NIH
funding in so many other areas of
research niña is driving innovation
advances discoveries that improve the
mental and physical health of older
Americans they're responsible for
leading the national research effort to
combat Alzheimer's through effective
early interventions and novel drug
treatments so we say thank you to you
thank you for being here and for your
great leadership finally I would
personally like to recognize all of the
doctors the nurses the scholars the
researchers here today you work day in
and day out in labs and clinics in
nursing homes and in hospitals to push
the edge of the envelope to push the
frontiers of knowledge to care for our
seniors and to save lives I'm in all I
am in awe always of what you do so many
of you know that I am a survivor of
ovarian cancer and I was so fortunate
that my cancer was discovered in stage
one and I went under I was in treatment
for several months I'm cancer-free for
27 years and I am here today because of
the grace of God and biomedical research
and their great work that you do here
and so I have as again so much respect
for what you are able to do to make a
difference in people's lives and I
believe that all medical research is
important but the aging research
conducted and supported here at the
center is particularly vital at this
moment when we are not only experiencing
the graying of America but more and more
Americans as we said are living longer
than ever and it will be on Christmas
Eve that my mother will be 100 years old
and that to me is I'm trying to wrap
myself around the fact that my mother is
100 years old in addition to which I
have to plan a party or do something to
acknowledge this effort but it's it's so
incredible um and um and I might add
that she does she is out every day I
have caregivers because I'm in
Washington I people who come in from
seven to seven at night and then from
seven to seven in the in the morning and
so forth and she goes out every day and
get her hair done every day and last
night she SAT with me as either a great
honor of being inducted into the
Connecticut women's hall of fame and we
had the video up there and does she get
it all no but she gets enough of it so
that there again is some value her own
sense of value at whatever she can
understand today and what her life is
about and according to the
administration on aging seniors make up
about one out of every eight Americans
and by 2030 that number will be one in
five then only 17 years from now there
will be over 72 million seniors in our
nation over twice as many as in 2000 as
a community and as a country we need to
be ready for this surgeon seniors as the
baby boom grows older and often times
you know my mom she retired in her 80s
from the New Haven Board of Aldermen and
for a number of years after that she
would she would say to me and I hear
this in senior centers because I get to
visit a lot of these places all of the
time you know these years of after you
know retirement the the golden years
presumably the golden years where not
only with my mother but I've heard so
many other seniors describe him as the
lead years as the lead because of you
know and they're mostly women women live
longer than men
sorry guys what can I tell you but we do
and we are more in danger of being in
poverty because of wages and because of
a retirement security and pensions and
because in and out of the workforce
there's not that much there in social
security at the end of the line so the
highest demographic for people in
poverty today are women who are over the
age of 65 or 70 years old so we need to
be about that quality of life which is
what you do we need the research that
you in this room undertake daily we need
to improve care we need to inform our
policies support the work that you do we
have to support the investments that
make all of this groundbreaking research
that you do possible and this is
something that I don't say in a
self-serving way I fight for every day I
am NOT a scientist some of the words i
can't pronounce i'm not i am a budget
appropriator but i believe in the
fundamental value of research and where
it can take us and where it has taken us
i am the senior Democrat on the
subcommittee that oversees the niña of
the NIH funding and I know that the most
important thing that I can do is to help
Americans live longer but to live
healthier lives is to fight for those
investments in your hard work and as
much as eighty five percent of Yale's
federal research portfolio is funded by
the National Institutes of Health I will
tell you this juncture just for a second
that we have serious difficulty with the
appropriations process today
where it plays out this dysfunction that
is occurring in washington plays out in
this committee dr. Hodgins knows this
was a committee where you had the most
and the broadest based bipartisan
support of any of the Committees of the
federal government and particularly in
the area of research because we had a
sense none of us are scientists none of
us are doctors or researchers but we
have a sense that we had a
responsibility to appropriate resources
and not earmark them for a specific
purpose but say here is the money you
place it where the greatest need is that
is beginning to unravel in so many ways
and if dr. Collins were here dr. Francis
Collins ahead of the NIH were here
someone who I admired deeply I will tell
you that two years ago we on the
Appropriations Committee all of the
various agencies that that come up and
are funded through labor health and
education and Human Services come before
a committee and make their case when I
served earlier on the Appropriations
Committee the NIH is to come up and all
of the Institute's were there they
talked about their groundbreaking
research they talked about where we were
going and the interplay amongst the
Institute's and how that research
overlapped with one another and and it
in a very positive sense two years ago
the committee chairman would not allow
dr. Collins to come and testify before
the Appropriations Committee not only
did we have all of the Institute's we
used to bring them in one at a time
after that two layouts
cific Lee where they were going what's
what they were doing and the
groundbreaking efforts that were
underway they were deny the director of
the National Institutes of Health a
platform to testify before us I asked
the committee chairman he did others did
they said no what I wound up doing
because I have such a high regard for
the NIH is I invited him to my home and
I invited members of Congress to come to
listen to him about what was going on at
the NIH so they would have some idea of
how important it is for us to be
supportive of this effort one other
point to let you know is this year this
year because of the cuts the federal
cuts you know as sequestration that's
across the board cuts to every
department when the labor Health
Education human services bill came up to
be discussed that bill never even made
it to a subcommittee because the number
was so low since 2010 this subcommittee
has taken a seventeen percent cut and
all of the programs that it undertakes
the Ryan budget had billions of dollars
in cuts to the NIH this bill that didn't
see the light of day though I saw a
draft of the bill had an additional 1.6
billion power to the enemy that is
criminal in my mind that is criminal in
my mind we passed the Affordable Care
Act it was one of my proudest moments in
the Congress but equally as proud was I
in doubling the NIH budget between 1998
and 2003 something we need to do again
that was done on a bipartisan basis with
people like a John Porter my Republican
colleague Ralph regula
others came together with david obie on
the Democratic side on a bill natural
others who recognized how valuable
research is and you know I'm going to
enlist your help here we were never
meant to go backward in funding for the
NIH we need your help I asked for your
help please make your voices heard you
have standing I am I'm not a scientist
not a researcher you are your voices
carry and they can tell us they can send
a message that unfortunately myself or
some of my other colleagues cannot send
that doubling resulted in real dividends
here at Yale scientists recently
developed a new way to prevent staph
infections by genetically manipulating
cells they've identified a single
molecule that impacts learning in memory
suggesting new treatments for diseases
like Alzheimer's all of the
groundbreaking research I mentioned
early relies on NIH and niña funding if
you factor in population growth and
inflation NIH funding right now is over
fourteen percent below what it was in
2010 the number of research grants is
lower than it has been since 2001 this
as I said diminishes the capability to
fund research conduct clinical trials
and develop new life-saving treatments
you know better than anyone else that
medical breakthroughs just don't happen
by some alchemy they don't they happen
because of hard work and insights of
medical researchers and the strong
support of the NIH and it is support
that leads to groundbreaking discovery
if we do not support this funding we
would only recognize the tremendous
losses years down the road when the
benefits of the research is not
forthcoming it would negatively affect
the health of every American the
discovery of fundamental knowledge about
how we grow how we age become ill made
dramatically slowed so too made the
treatments for the prevention and the
treatment of disease cutting-edge
treatments for cancer for heart disease
for stroke for osteoporosis arthritis
that is what medical research gives us
the gift of good health the gift of
golden years and the gift of life it is
a gift that I have treasured for over a
quarter century since my cancer
diagnosis and it is a gift that every
American deserves as they grow older so
I thank you for what you're doing here
at the pepper Center you're broadening
our understanding of aging and know that
I am proud to stand with you and the
amazing and the historic work that you
all do you help to improve the health of
all Americans and research into aging as
i said is something that we should all
support and we should rally around I
again enlist your help take the
opportunity because you have all kinds
of networks of people and Dean Alpern
doesn't have to call me though I love to
talk with him but you have people and
networks all over the country those are
folks ought to get to members of
Congress and tell them what is it risk
what is at stake and it isn't for people
other than members because these issues
affect all of our lives we are not
immune members of Congress for what
happens in the lives of older Americans
and we too are growing and aging thank
you I know it's going to be a great
afternoon for all of it
you